last week we discussed the impending
doom of Hollywood as the media was
frantically warning us the entire
entertainment industry was on the verge
of collapse thanks to a writer's strike
and actor strike and a series of
supposed Blockbusters that turned out to
be flops and this was in some ways an
ironic combination of factors given that
the quality and performance of these
movies would seem to indicate that the
writers and actors had already been on
strike for many decades the average
viewer will come out of the latest
Hollywood dud here that the writers had
been on strike or just went on strike
and respond wait the movie had writers
it already seems like these films are
being generated by Ai and now they
really will be and I don't think we'll
be able to tell much of a difference
when that happens
so it has been a gloomy time in
Hollywood all around but this weekend
has given them a glimmer of hope false
hope I think and I hope that we'll teach
them all the wrong lessons but hope all
the same The Hollywood Reporter declares
a box office stunner a historic weekend
for movies they report quote the summer
box office just went nuclear filmmaker
Greta gerwig's female fueled Barbie
opened to a historic 155 million dollars
domestically a threshold usually
reserved for male-driven superhero fair
or Marquis IP such as the final Harry
Potter movie it came in well ahead of an
expected 90 million dollars to 110
million dollars and helped fuel one of
the biggest weekends in history Barbie
which brings to life Mattel's iconic
fashion doll is also strutting to big
numbers overseas the pick launched to an
impressive 182 million dollars from 70
markets for a global bow of 337 million
dollars against a 145 million production
budget in North America Barbie scored
the biggest domestic start ever for a
movie directed by a woman solo or
otherwise
after gushing for several more
paragraphs about Barbie the article does
mention that Christopher Nolan's film
Oppenheimer also opened this weekend to
an enormous Hall breaking in 80 million
dollars this makes it Nolan's biggest
opening weekend for any of his
non-batman films especially impressive
far more impressive than Barbie's
performance as we'll see because his
movie is an original three-hour R-rated
historical drama it is very difficult to
make that kind of film into a smash hit
people don't generally flock to theaters
to watch incredibly long character
studies about historical figures that is
unprecedented or nearly so
there is however plenty of precedent for
moviegoers crowding theaters to watch
movies based on familiar brands
okay it's not really historic audiences
are increasingly becoming bored with
franchise films and brand films as
Indiana Jones and the Flash and Little
Mermaid and many others have discovered
but if there is a brand with a large and
dedicated fan base that hasn't had its
own film in a long time then it'll
probably do pretty well in its opening
weekend and that's the story with Barbie
the movie is a Smash Hit because Barbie
as a brand is a Smash Hit
the quality of the film doesn't make a
difference the directing the acting the
writing none of that factors into the
equation
okay it could have just been a movie
where you're literally staring at a
Barbie doll sitting in the corner and
because it's called Barbie it would have
made 150 million dollars
mothers and daughters did not file into
the theaters over the weekend because
they really wanted to see what Greta
Gerwig cooked up in order they come
because they're a big Margot Robbie fans
they came because it's Barbie it's a
brand they like and American consumers
are conditioned to salivate whenever
their favorite brand rings the bell
this weekend was not really a
Vindication of Hollywood or the
filmmakers behind Barbies but rather if
anything a Vindication of Pavlov and his
dogs
Barbie's box office performance is a
result of conditioning and not much else
now if anyone deserves the credit though
for the biggest box office debut for any
female director in history it is not the
female director but the marketing
department
because they're the ones who knew enough
to lie about the true content and
message of the film
because as we've now discovered though
it shouldn't really have come as a
surprise to anyone the Barbie movie is a
preachy feminist screed about taking
down the patriarchy it is a gender
studies lecture in Barbie Packaging
and I know this not because I watched
the film I'd rather jump feet first into
a wood chipper than sit through that
film I don't need to watch Barbie to
know that it's bad for the same reason
that I don't need to pull a rotten onion
out of the garbage and eat it in order
to know that I won't like the taste
I've never thrown myself into a volcano
but I feel that I can safely say that
the experience would be unpleasant and
probably a little hot
so some books can be judged by their
covers absolutely or at least by their
back covers where you find the
description and we now have descriptions
of the Barbie movie which make the
themes clear something that the
marketing never did and intentionally so
Fox reports quote Hollywood movie
critics are widely praising Barbie as
the most unwavering feminist summer
blockbuster ever to exist giving the new
film particular adoration for its
messaging around the patriarchy and
gender roles the film starving starring
Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling both a
strong 89 critic score Rotten Tomatoes
with many reviews surprised by director
Greta gerwig's willingness to engage in
extensive social commentary
so surprising
the Hollywood film director is engaging
in political commentary as no one's ever
heard of such a thing
quote once in equal parts fascinating
and controversial Mattel toy both loved
and hated a tiny wasted vacuously
smiling slender doll designed like a
straight male fantasy is now the
complicated feminist symbol of
empowerment in gerwig's hands the rap
wrote quote but we aren't talking about
an empty Hugo you go girl kind of
empowerment here that would be too
simple-minded for Gerwig whose
articulate and accessible feminism has
always been fiercely multifaceted and
complex
Barbie is both a master's thesis on
feminism and an Austin powers-esque romp
the Globe and Mail noted the rep also
stated that the movie delivers a fierce
feminist statement dressed in pink while
the Globe and Mail declared that the
film quote most is most captivating and
unwaveringly feminist summer blockbuster
ever to exist meanwhile Indy wire
praised the films outside the box and
funny feminist Fantasia and Signal out
gossin's performance of Newfound male
rage and patriarchal power as a
particular highlight
funny you know they didn't tout this
thing as a master thesis on feminism in
the trailer I can guarantee you they
didn't put that they're not going to put
that on the poster okay a master thesis
on feminism come on bring your kids
you know a company is looking out for
you when they actually upgrade your
service and don't charge you for it this
is great news for new and current Pure
Talk customers pure talk just added data
to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you consider pure talk
before but haven't made the switch take
a look again for just twenty dollars a
month you'll get unlimited talk text and
now 50 more 5G data plus their new
mobile hotspot this is why I love Pure
Talk they're veteran owned and only hire
the best customer service team located
right here in the great USA most
families are saving almost a thousand
dollars a year while enjoying the most
Dependable 5G networks in America
remember you vote with how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to puretalk.com Walsh
you'll save an additional 50 off your
first month because they actually value
you that's puretalk.com Walsh puretalk
Wireless for Americans by Americans
companies are strong armoring their
customers to support abortion canceling
customers for their political views and
making a mockery of women by supporting
transgender models no government
agencies institution or company is
allowed to just be what it is anymore
and focus on fulfilling the task that it
was made to fulfill a beer company can't
just make beer anymore their primary
concern is not with brewing and
distributing beer but with showing their
support for the left's political and
cultural agenda well Public Square
offers a new solution Public Square is
an app and website where you can get
connected to tens of thousands of
businesses from all different industries
that share your values uh your your
values for Life family and freedom
Public Square also offers discounts to
many high quality businesses on the
platform so you can actually have an
incentive to spend money with companies
that don't hate you whether you're
looking for new athletic clothing that
knows what a woman is a banking partner
you can count on or simply a new
restaurant in the area where you're not
going to get lectured about uh you know
your political views as you're trying to
enjoy a meal whatever you're looking for
head over to
publicsq.com Public Square is free to
join as a customer or as a business
owner you can now get started at
publicescue.com or download their app
today that's publicsq.com
they didn't title the movie The
Adventures of feminist Barbie
no mentions of patriarchy or male rage
either in any of the marketing it is
again not in the least bit surprising
that these themes dominate the film not
surprising to us anyway as people who
pay attention and are aware of what's
happening in the world and in our
culture but the average Barbie viewer is
on the other hand
um oftentimes not so aware and that's
why the sleight of hand trick worked
dangle a funny and fun and nostalgic and
family-friendly Barbie film in front of
the audience and then when you have them
in the seat whack them over the head
with the feminist stick
sell them the Barbie doll and let them
open the package and find Gloria Steinem
inside
now we know about the aggressive
male-hating feminist bent of this film
thanks in part to some brave souls like
Ben Shapiro who actually sat and endured
it so they could report on his content
this is a form I have to say of
journalistic courage far more impressive
than reporters who cover War zones
especially the reporters in Ukraine
right now but we also know about the
movie's real message from the generally
positive reviews of liberal movie
critics the review with variety gets
into some of the details that the film's
marketing material smartly glossed over
a quote at the same time Barbie is
experiencing her rude awakening Ken's
busy Ken is busy filling his empty head
with all the possibilities that
patriarchy entails in Barbie land Ken's
job is a deliberately ill-defined
afterthought basically just Beach
whereas in the real world dudes rule an
idea he takes back to Barbie land with
pointantly absurd results brainwashing
all the women who into behaving like
obedient Housewives
this is apparently the major underlying
theme in the movie Men in Barbie land
are uh useless and stupid
but then men in the real world are
useless and stupid but also violent
predatory and in control of everything
Ken Witnesses this Dynamic and tries to
export the patriarchy back to Barbie
land and they actually call it the
patriarchy in the film that phrase is
used many times
I should mention that the variety review
is not entirely positive okay to the
credit uh they do have some criticisms
of the film
including you know it takes issue with
the movie and specifically with the way
that men are portrayed
but the issue according to film critic
Peter debug is that all of this time
spent making men look terrible might
risk taking the spotlight off of women
so there's nothing wrong with sending
the message that all men are dumb pigs
but you should give them less screen
time in the process Peter says quote
It's upsetting in a useful way to see
Barbie confronted with the overnight
impact of rampant patriarchy a concept
that has rarely looked more off-putting
than the frat boy Fantasy character here
think of it as the misogynistic
alternative marketed by old school beer
commercials the polar opposite of
Mattel's mid-80s we girls can do
anything right Barbie campaign well the
Barbie's plot to take back the
government Gerwig gives all the Ken
dolls an over-the-top musical number I'm
just Ken which is so amusingly
self-involved at risks subverting the
very point the movie's trying to make if
Barbie is all about centering and
celebrating women why let Ken steal the
show
so this is the modern media for you the
only problem with demonizing men is that
it requires you to talk about men too
much
and that's the Barbie movie for you too
thousands of moms took their daughters
to see this thing over the weekend
and um you know it is a it is a
certainly a wonderful movie to show your
daughter if you want your daughter to be
a vapid man-hating harpy
if that's your great dream for your
daughter then by all means show them
Greta gerwig's Barbie
but this is not actually what most
mothers want for their daughters
so for comparison's sake contrast this
with the general public reaction when a
movie wears its feminist credentials on
its sleeve
take the upcoming Snow White remake for
example we've already seen how they
traded in Snow White for snow Brown
casting a Hispanic woman in the title
role and for whatever reason they
decided that the most inclusive approach
is to take casting opportunities away
from actors with dwarfism by turning the
Seven Dwarves into regular-sized carnies
but they're also changing the whole Arc
and theme of the story to make it more
feminist as this interview with the
Stars revealed watch
you said you were bringing a Modern Edge
to it on stage what do you mean by that
I just mean that it's no longer 1937.
she's not gonna be safe for The Prince
and she's not going to be dreaming about
true love she's dreaming about becoming
the leader she knows she can be and the
leader that her late father told her
that she could be if she was Fearless
Fair Brave and true and so it's just a
really incredible story for I think
young people everywhere to see
themselves in
uh it's not 1937 anymore that's true
more is the pity
now we're not going to focus on the
point that the taller woman there Gal
Gadot is playing the evil queen and the
shorter one is playing Snow White now
remember that in the story The Queen is
supposed to be jealous of Snow White's
Beauty
you know mirror mirror on the wall who's
the fairest one of all and the mirror is
supposed to tell her that it's snow
white so we're supposed to buy that okay
we're supposed to buy that Gal Gadot is
asked who's the fairest one of all and
it's not her it's Rachel zegler
um this is a real problem kind of hard
to pull off in this case as the evil
queen is significantly more attractive
than snow white but yeah putting that
aside the point is that the clip you
just heard has been roundly mocked by
nearly everyone
the movie is destined to be a worse flop
than the woke Little Mermaid
bastardization was I mean it's
guaranteed to be a flop
because nobody wants to see a fairy tale
where the Damsel in Distress no longer
needs saving and the central romance has
been replaced with a dreary sermon about
self-empowerment
nobody wants to see Snow White become a
corporate middle manager and Achieve
true happiness by moving into a
two-bedroom condo with her cat
they want to see her get saved by The
Prince and fall in love that's what
people want to see
when you advertise ahead of time that
your film is going to is going to go the
former route rather than the latter
going the feminist route rather than the
Classic route nobody will see it
so feminism has to trick you it has to
smuggle itself in it can't walk in the
front door announcing its arrival
because people will will scream and run
out the back door away from it
that's because despite what snow Brown
claims nearly all women innately desire
a man to protect them and provide for
them that's what almost all women want
women want to be swept off their feet by
Prince Charming that's that's why these
stories have lived on for centuries and
resonated with each new generation
the feminist fairy tale resonates with
no one
it's a vision of what feminism wants
women to do and and what it wants women
to think and what it wants women to want
but it will always ring false because it
is false
now
that's not to say that feminism hasn't
won many disciples in the modern world
obviously it has
proven to be a devastating and lethal
Force far deadlier than the bomb at the
center of the other Blockbuster this
weekend
feminism has killed 60 million babies
and that's just the beginning of the
destruction that it has wrought on the
world but it wins inherence through
brainwashing intense and constant
indoctrination especially in public
schools and by playing on a woman's
resentment and hatred and self-pity and
desire to blame others for her problems
you know this can work in the culture
unfortunately it doesn't really work as
a fairy tale because fairy tales are
aspirational and fanciful and whimsical
feminism on the other hand is bass and
vulgar and hateful
and it also doesn't work in marketing
materials for a film based on a beloved
children's toy
that's why they hit it away tucked it
under all the pink and plastic and then
came out with the man-hating
sledgehammer when the audience was
already sitting in the seats
so the only question is whether those
mothers who took their daughters then
you know to see this film did they then
spend the whole ride home explaining why
all that stuff in the movie was wrong
better yet as soon as they saw it was
really happening did they uh grab their
daughter by the hand and leave the
theater before the movie ended
or were they too obtuse to notice the
toxic feminist message even when it was
delivered with a sledgehammer
or were many of these mothers already
men hating feminists themselves and so
they didn't see any problem with it
I suspect a mix of all these options has
played out this past weekend but I hope
there were plenty in the first category
and for any parents who hadn't yet taken
their daughters to see this movie but
planned on going in the future
well
now you know better thanks for checking
out this video if you'd like to listen
to my full podcast on the go you can
check out the Matt wall show on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts